uh lee for those back on
stage at live shows roughly how much
brand new material do you work into your
sets i'm caught between polishing more
establishments and doing really brand
new stuff
well when it comes to working out new
material a usual rule of thumb
is weave it in between material you know
works so you kind of couch it
in between jokes that you're confident
in
so you get them laughing on a confident
bit throw in something new
if it works keep trying the new if it
doesn't
you have a better joke to back it up
when the new joke falls flat
it's cushioned between a good bit
and a good bit so when it falls if it
falls
then you have a good bit to pick it back
up again so it's usually you want to
open up with something you're confident
in
something you've done before that is
more established and then get into the
new material if it's a five minute set
it's usually kind of like
open up with 60 to 90 seconds of
material you're confident in
try a few new things in the middle of
the set and then close out the set with
some stronger material as well
that's usually the rule of thumb when
trying out new material
now some open mics you know they're
these are
these are only suggestion these are not
laws you know so you can make them your
own
but i've i've found it helps me to
deliver newer stuff more confidently
if it's coming off a laugh of a previous
joke
so i can just kind of ride that wave
into there
[Music]
you